Comment se fait-il que le super crash annoncé depuis tant d’années n’a toujours pas eu lieu ?
Tu as plusieurs arguments pour défendre que ça n’a pas eu lieu.
Pour que ça ait eu lieu, il faut que suffisamment de gens soient convaincus que ça va avoir lieu et agissent en conséquence.
Tu sais, c'est toujours comme ça.
Autoréalisateur.
C’est complètement autoréalisateur.
Depuis 2008, les banques centrales sont beaucoup intervenues sur les marchés financiers sur différents endroits pour les stabiliser.
Et donc, il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont convaincus de ce qu’ils appellent un banque central put.
C’est un terme financier pour dire que
quoiqu’il arrive, la banque centrale sera là pour soutenir les marchés, là où ça pète.
Parce qu’on sait que si les marchés s’effondrent, derrière il y a une crise économique qui arrive.
Déjà, les banques centrales tentent d’éviter les crises économiques.
Ça fait partie des institutions qui sont là pour essayer d’éviter les crises économiques.
Mais aussi, parce que les banquiers centraux savent qu’on va les blâmer eux.
On va trouver un moyen de dire : “ah mais c’est parce que vous avez disrupté les marchés en 2008 en essayant de les sauver, il aurait fallu les laisser s’effondrer
pour que ça nettoie les cancers à droite, à gauche
et qu’on reparte sur de bonnes bases.
Ce qui est évidemment une bêtise, c’est complètement idéologique de penser ça, qu’il y aurait des cancers dans les marchés et que si on les nettoie, ça marche mieux.
Les marchés sont chaotiques par essence. Voilà, c’est tout. Il y a ce double truc.
Un, je ne veux pas que l’économie s’effondre. Deux, je sais que ça va me retomber dessus si je n’interviens pas pour sauver le truc.
Donc, ça veut dire qu’il y a des moyens d’éviter que l’économie s’effondre.
Si tu dis qu’ils font tout ce qu’il faut pour que ça ne s’effondre pas.
Pas que l’économie s’effondre, parce que l’économie c’est plus compliqué. Que les marchés financiers s’effondrent,
ça oui, tu as des moyens pour le faire.
Ça peut durer indéfiniment alors ? Faire tenir le truc indéfiniment ?
Le truc, c’est toujours la même chose, ce qui tiens,
c’est vraiment le fait qu’il y ait suffisamment de gens qui sont persuadés que ça ne va pas s’effondrer.
Donc, l’idée c’est, la banque centrale arrive et dit si moi j’achète x milliards de ça, est-ce que c’est suffisant
parce que x milliard ne va faire que 1% ou 0,5% du total, ils ne vont pas faire 100%,
ce serait la fin s’ils faisaient 100%,
ils ne peuvent faire qu’un certain pourcentage.
Est-ce que le pourcentage qu’ils vont donner va être suffisant pour convaincre la masse de
“OK, c’est bon, ils sont là pour nous sauver”.
Et donc ça, pour le moment, c’est suffisant,
mais peut-être que tu arriveras à un moment donné où même la banque centrale dirait “c’est bon j’achète x milliards”.
Les gens se disent “nan mais quand même, ce n’est pas possible” et vendre.
En fait, c’est ça le truc. C’est que pour que les marchés s’effondrent, il faudrait que les gens vendent en masse.
C’est ça, et qu’il n’y ait pas d’acheteur en face.
C’est souvent ça qui se passe.
En fait, pour que tu aies une variation de prix très importante, ce qui se passe, c’est que le mec dit “Ok, ça valait 40 hier, donc aujourd’hui, je décide de vendre à 40.”
Il va sur les marchés, il dit “Ok, moi je veux bien vendre à 40” et là, y a personne qui dit “je veux bien acheter à 40”.
Il dit “39 alors ? Quelqu’un ? Personne ? 38 ? 37 ? Bordel ! Et tac tac tac. 30 ? 25 ?” Et ok à 25, il trouve quelqu’un.
Donc le dernier prix, c’était 25, donc tout le monde utilise cette référence
comme étant le dernier en prix et donc personne va proposer 40 maintenant.
On va tous tourner autour de 25. Etc. etc et ça continue de descendre.
Du coup voilà. Les marchés s’effondrent. L’économie se crashe.
Mais l’argent ne disparaît pas ? L’argent est toujours là ?
Non, l’argent ne disparaît pas. Alors ça c’est aussi un truc…
Le sentiment de richesse, il ne vient pas nécessairement de la quantité d’argent que tu as dans ton portefeuille, il vient aussi du fait que tu dis.
Je sais pas, cette table qui a une certaine valeur, j’ai ma maison qui a une certaine valeur
et donc j’ai des produits financiers qui ont une certaine valeur.
Et tout ça participe au sentiment de richesse.
Et je me dis, si jamais j’ai un souci, je peux vendre ça, je peux vendre ça, je peux vendre ça.
Mais si je vois le prix de tout ce que j’ai partir par terre, je me dis “Mais en fait, je suis pauvre”.
Du coup, mon argent que j’avais dans ma poche
que j’étais OK pour le dépenser,
bah maintenant je ne vais plus le dépenser, parce que je me dis que ça, au moins, c’est sécurisé,
ça ne perd pas de valeur, je le garde
et si je le garde comme les dépenses des uns sur les revenus des autres. Bah là, ton économie est impactée.
C’est ça, le moyen de transmission des marchés financiers qui sont fictifs au sens de
c’est juste la valeur des choses qui existent.
Et ces choses ne disparaissent pas, elles restent là.
Et l’économie où on fabrique de vraies choses, mais pour fabriquer de vraies choses, il faut des gens qui consomment,
et des entreprises qui décident d’investir pour fabriquer des trucs.
Et ça, c’est vraiment psychologique. Quand elle voit que toutes les choses perdent de la valeur,
ils perdent confiance et plus personne n’agit, plus personne ne veut se lancer dans l’économie.
- Et ça crée des crises.
- D'accord.
D’accord, donc en réalité pour qu’il n’y ait jamais de crises, il faudrait que les gens aient confiance en permanence aux marchés, en l’économie,
continuent à investir… en fait, c’est ça quoi.
Pour se sauver, il faut avoir envie de se sauver.
Après, tu as aussi les dimensions qui sont physiques, au sens que tu as besoin d’énergie pour fabriquer des trucs, tu as besoin de matières premières,
tu as besoin de gens qui sont formés, tu as besoin tu vois etc.
Il y a des tas de contraintes, mais une contrainte qui s’ajoute à ça, c’est effectivement le fait que
tout le monde a bien confiance, tout le monde a envie de dépenser, tout le monde a confiance dans le système.
[inaudible] potentielle comme le COVID.
Voilà.
Là tu as une contrainte supplémentaire où tu dis :
“Bah, en fait, vous ne pouvez pas aller fabriquer des trucs, parce que sinon vous vous rendez malades. Et donc, on arrête de fabriquer des trucs."
Donc là, ton économie est obligée de ralentir.
Récemment, je lisais un article sur un astéroïde
qui contient potentiellement plusieurs centaines de milliards de métaux précieux. Ça te dit un truc cet astéroïde-là.
Y en a pas mal, je crois. Mais celui-là en particulier...
Il y en a un en particulier, il représente plus que tout l’économie terrestre réunie.
Et donc voilà, il y a des ressources, des matières premières.
Et évidemment, il y a des entreprises qui commencent à envisager d’aller miner sur l’astéroïde.
Admettons que ça arrive par exemple. Mettons que toutes ces ressources débarquent sur la Terre.
Qu’est-ce que ça aurait comme impact sur l’économie ?
Tout à coup, les choses auraient moins de valeur, puisqu’il y en aurait beaucoup plus ?
Tes matières premières pourraient perdre de la valeur. Après, c’est toujours pareil.
Tes matières premières, c’est offre/demande.
Donc, si ça, ça commençait à débarquer et que du jour au lendemain, tu as des tas d’entrepreneurs qui arrivent et qui disent “Ok mais moi, du coup, je vais monter une entreprise de ça” Tu pourrais avoir la demande qui augmente en même temps que l’offre.
Et ça serait proportionnel ouais.
C’est possible. Il faut toujours penser aux deux côtés du truc.
Et après, il faut voir aussi que, à chaque fois les financiers, ils essaient de lire l’avenir.
Donc, ils se disent,
quelle va être l’impact de ce truc-là.
Et c’est pas évident que tout le monde arrive à la même conclusion.
C’est la conclusion du plus grand monde qui va impacter les prix dans un sens ou dans l’autre.
C’est un peu comme avec le pétrole, où tu te dis, s’il y a moins de pétrole,
du coup l’économie ralentit parce qu’elle est dépendante du pétrole.
Et si l’économie ralentit, dans ce cas, les entreprises qui produisent du pétrole produisent trop,
par rapport à la demande.
Et si l’offre est supérieure à la demande, le prix baisse. Mais si le prix baisse, alors l’économie repart.
Et donc du coup, la demande va être supérieure à l’offre. Et donc le prix montre. Mais si…
quand est-ce que tu t’arrêtes de raisonner dans le futur et quand est-ce que tu prends une décision sur ça va monter ou ça va baisser.
Ça y est, on a un épisode de plus là ?
Sauf qu’on ira jamais miner des astéroïdes. Donc voilà, problème résolu.
J’ai assisté à un rassemblement où plein de gens donnaient des conférences.
Et c’était un truc d’entreprise,
c’était quand même pas mal de frime, c’était moi et mon entreprise, on va faire des trucs super.
Donc il y avait des gens qui promettaient l’immortalité, des trucs incroyables.
Ils sont juste très convaincus, plus convaincus qu’ils n’ont de preuve.
Et il y avait un gars justement, lui montait une start up pour aller miner des astéroïdes
Et qui était très optimiste, très “Venez, investissez, ça va être super”.
Et c’est la première fois que j’ai entendu parler de ça. Et c’est toujours des gens très convaincants.
Voilà c’est tout.
D'accord, je pensais que tu allais dire “son truc, c’est complètement…
Non non, franchement son truc, la façon dont il le présentait, c’était crédible.
Il était là “Voilà, on a les investissements, on a des fusées, on va envoyer des sondes,
quand on aura détecter une charge de métaux suffisamment importants,...”
Je suis sûr qu’un mec comme Musk est sur le coup quoi.
Le mec a des fusées, de l’argent à ne plus savoir quoi en foutre. Forcément qu’il va aller miner des astéroïdes. Ca me parait être l’étape d’après logique.
Pourquoi tu penses qu’on ne le fera jamais ?
Parce que ce n’est pas rentable du tout.
Ah oui, c’est trop cher d’y aller ?
Oui, c’est trop cher d’y aller, ça vaut pas le coup pour ce qu’on va ramener. Il vaut mieux juste ne pas y aller.
En fait, il y a d’autres trucs qui pourraient être intéressants, c’est de miner de l’eau ou des ressources qui peuvent servir à des voyages spatiaux.
Genre ça fait un retour.
Ça pour le coup, ça peut valoir le détour.
C’est tout quoi. Sinon, il y a un autre truc qui a le vent en poupe,
c’est le fait de miner des terres rares dans les abysses.
Et ça, c’est peut-être un peu plus réaliste et à mon avis, ça va se faire.
Donc on pourrait avoir des mines dans les abysses qui vont encore plus dévaster les fonds marins.
Y en a qui sont sur le coup.
Je crois que le Luxembourg est sur le coup. Peut-être la Norvège ou la Suède je ne sais plus. Mais ça, c’est en train de se faire pour le coup.
C’est beaucoup plus réaliste que d’aller miner des astéroïdes.
Il y a quoi dans les fonds marins de précieux ?
Bah y a des nodules polymétallique, ça va être des métaux, des terres rares, des machins comme ça.
Des trucs qui nous servent pour des technologies quoi.
Comment ça se fait qu’on n’a toujours pas trouvé de substituts au métal rare,
tu sais, pour les téléphones là, qui fait qu’il y a des guerres au Congo.
Comment ça s’appelle… le coltan. Tu vois le coltan ?
Je ne connais pas ce truc.
- C’est pas possible. Tu ne peux pas ne pas connaître le coltan.
- Ah, le coltan.
Le coltan, c’est ce métal rare qui est miné à un seul endroit sur Terre, donc le Congo.
- Comment tu as dit ?
- Le cobalt ?
Ah non, c'est le coltan.
Le coltan, je ne connais pas du tout.
Donc c’est un métal rarissime et c’est ce qui permet à nos téléphones de marcher
et ça alimente des guerres au Congo.
On n’a pas d’autres options manifestement. Et Charles Villa a fait un reportage où il est allé dans les mines de coltan, il descend dans les galeries, et évidemment, il n’y a absolument aucune mesure de sécurité.
C’est des gosses en plus qui minent des ces trucs-là. Ils meurent la plupart du temps dans les tunnels parce que ça s’effondre.
C’est des tombeaux, tu vois.
Et quand ça arrive, ils font juste un trou ailleurs.
Et donc Charles y est allé. Il est descendu dans le truc et quand tu vois la vidéo, tu te dis qu’il ne va jamais en sortir.
Parce que c’est hyper étroit et une fois arrivé au fond de la galerie, tu as deux pauvres mecs comme ça là en train de creuser leur truc.
Donc c’est vraiment l’argent de la guerre et du sang. Parce que tu as des chefs de guerre qui exploitent des gosses
et tout ça ensuite alimente le marché des téléphones.
La question c’est, comment c’est possible qu’on ait pas trouvé de substitut à ça. Comment on peut continuer à entretenir cet enfer.
Et tu as des marques comme Fairphone qui proposent des alternatives.
C’est beaucoup plus cher, c’est aussi pour ça que le coltan est utilisé, c’est parce que c’est pas cher.
Et dans le reportage, tu vois les gars
qui expliquent qu’en fait le prix, c’est les marques qui le fixent.
Charles demande à un mec : “mais comment ça se fait que le prix a baissé de 20% comme ça ?”.
Le mec dit “Bah nous, on les vend au prix qu’ils nous demandent vous allez le vendre à tel prix”. Et ils vendent.
Donc voilà. Je suis content de t’avoir fait découvrir un minerai.
Bah merci, je ne connaissais pas. C’est cobalt et tantanium je crois. Un mélange des deux.
Coltan, c’est colombo et tantalite. Colombo, je ne savais même pas que ça existait.
Mais tu me demandes pourquoi il n’y a pas d’alternative. En même temps, ça ne se passe pas chez nous.
Ce que je veux dire c’est comment c’est possible que sur toute la planète, on ait pas des minerais qui puissent avoir la même fonction, les mêmes propriétés.
Parce que je crois que la propriété du coltan, c’est qu’il est très résistant à l’humidité.
Donc, il y a une histoire de batterie, dans la batterie, il y a de l’acide. Ce coltan résiste à fond.
Et c’est ce qui permet au téléphone de durer longtemps.
Je trouve ça fou, c’est un peu comme le vibranium dans les Marvel. Un métal qui n'existe qu'à un seul endroit sur Terre.
Ca, il faut en parler avec Rodolphe, “Le Réveilleur”.
Il a bossé pas mal sur les ressources métalliques.
Il ne m’a pas parlé de ce métal là. Mais par contre, ce qu’il me disait, c’est que, en gros les terres rares, ce n’est pas rare.
C’est intéressant ça.
Les terres rares, c’est pas de la terre et c'est pas rare.
C’est donc un mauvais nom.
Il disait en gros, le problème qu’on a c’est que pour l’instant, il y a beaucoup de métaux comme ça.
C’est des quantités infimes qu’on utilise dans les téléphones et dans les technologies d’une manière générale.
Donc en fait, la production de ce genre de trucs. Elle est toute toute toute petite si on compare à la quantité d’aluminium ou de fer qu’on va extraire.
Et donc en gros, le truc c’est que, bah oui pour l’instant, on mine dans 3 ou 4 pays,
parce qu’il n’y a pas besoin de plus et parce que c’est facile d’aller là-bas, on emploie des gamins, ça ne coûte pas cher.
Si demain on avait besoin d’une forte quantité, tu cherches limite en France, tu en trouves.
En gros l’idée c’est que, déjà il n’y a pas besoin de beaucoup, ensuite il y a des pressions, on ne veut pas ramener des mines dans les pays développés
parce qu’on se dit, les mines, c’est pour les pays en développement etc.
Et aussi quand tu regardes, après tu te dis, y a combien de cobalt sur Terre par exemple.
Tu vas regarder les estimations. Mais en vrai, les estimations, elles dépendent des pays qui ont fait des analyses de leurs sols pour essayer de savoir à peu près combien il y en a.
Et les pays qui font l’analyse du sol sur le cobalt,
ce ne sont que les pays producteurs de cobalt.
Donc les 3 ou 4 qu’il y a, et tous les autres pays ne sont pas sondés.
Après si tu fais par contre des extrapolations par rapport à
ce que tu devrais théoriquement pouvoir trouver dans la croûte terrestre etc.
Tu te rends compte qu’il y a des quantités énormes et qu’il y a beaucoup de métaux où c’est en fait…
En fait, ce titanium qui fait le coltan, si on va le chercher là-bas, c’est parce qu’il est surtout pas cher.
Là je vois sur Wikipedia qu’ils en produisaient au Canada aussi, ils pensent en Egypte. Après je sais pas, c’est Wikipedia.
J’ai vu aussi que dans le désert, le désert de sel. Le désert d’Uyuni. Le Salar d’Uyuni.
Il y a la plus grosse réserve mondiale de lithium.
Et la Bolivie, c’est un des pays les plus pauvres du monde. Et l’idée, c’était que grâce au Salar, tout à coup, ça allait devenir un pays plus riche parce que le lithium, pareil, c’est dans les batteries.
Et je ne sais pas où ça en est de ça, mais ce qui est sûr, c’est que c’est clairement pas la Bolivie qui doit profiter de ces ressources.
Ils doivent être envahis par les pays riches.
- En tout cas pas les Boliviens.
- Non, ça c'est sûr.
Ca après, c’est l’énorme problème de, tu sais, tu as une ressource dans ton pays, t’as pas les infrastructures pour aller les chercher.
T’as pas les entreprises, t’as pas les ingénieurs, t’as pas les connaissances. T’es obligé de faire venir les pays étrangers.
Et là eux ils arrivent, ils se font un peu concurrence entre eux mais potentiellement, ils discutent aussi entre eux. Et ils te pillent.
Si en plus le pays n’est pas démocratique, ils laissent un gros ticket au dictateur du coin et les gens, ils ne récupèrent rien derrière.
Et là tu vois au bout sur la vidéo tu sais qui te parlent de comment tu gardes le pouvoir.
Dans une démocratie, tu veux rendre les gens heureux parce que ton pouvoir dépend d’eux.
Mais dans une pas-démocratie, tu dépends de l’armée, surtout, qui te maintient au pouvoir. Il y a quelques généraux à bien grassement rémunérer et tout.
Surtout les pays où la ressource est principalement une ressource naturelle. Tu n’as pas besoin du peuple pour engendrer de la richesse. Bah là tu as tout intérêt à ne pas...
On va essayer de nouer ça aussi à des niveaux de complexité.
Etonnamment, les pays démocratiques, c’est les pays où il y a le plus de complexité dans la production.
Les industries dépendent les unes des autres. Et du coup, c’est très difficile de contrôler l’ensemble du système.
Du coup ça, ça se prête mal à de la dictature. Alors que par contre, un pays qui se focalise juste sur une ou deux ressources, ça c’est facile à contrôler.
C’est pas trop compliqué. Ils font un parallèle entre les pays qui sont peu complexes, ils regardent les industries et tout
ils font des grilles de complexité, ils font un score à la fin.
Et ils montrent que les pays les plus riches sont toujours les pays les plus complexes dans leur production.
Centraliser l’information et ton économie quelque part, tu peux les gérer.
Tandis que si tu es dans un pays sophistiqué, chacun a ses propres compétences, tu ne peux pas…
et tu es obligé d’investir dans des écoles qui font des formations spécialisées dans tel ou tel domaine. Et puis là du coup, tu ne peux plus contrôler…
Tu vois, cet argument il va un peu à l’encontre, tu sais Ricardo qui dit chaque pays doit se spécialiser dans ce dans quoi il est bon.
Bah le truc, tu dis, c’est que si tout le monde fait ça, tu as vraiment le pays qui fait le vin, le pays qui fait les chaussures, le pays qui…
Cette histoire de complexité contredit ça en disant “bah en fait non, si vous voulez vraiment devenir riche, il faut vraiment faire tout plein de trucs, parce qu’après, ça va être complémentaire
sans même avoir un projet de départ.
Le fait de faire un peu de ça, un peu de ça, un peu de ça et de laisser un peu libre les entrepreneurs, ils vont trouver des passerelles de connexion pour créer de nouveaux trucs.
Et en fait, c’est comme ça que tu t’enrichis, que tu crées de la valeur.
C’est une histoire de dépendance. Mais si ton économie dépend d’un truc et si tout d’un coup, il n’y a plus d’intérêt pour le truc…
Ça s'effondre.
Tu sais, c’est le Venezuela avec le pétrole là. Ils avaient ça.
Ils font que du pétrole. Enfin, pas que du pétrole. Des services, et sinon du pétrole.
Et donc du coup, pour avoir des services, il te faut des machines, il te faut des biens, tu ne peux pas vivre que de services.
Il te faut aussi du physique du réel.
Et donc le Vénézuela, ils ont leur économie tertiaire où ils ont beaucoup de monde. Notamment le service public etc. Ils peuvent se le permettre.
Et sinon, tout ce qui est production physique, c’est pétrole quoi. Tu vends à l’international. Tu récupères des dollars. Avec ces dollars, tu achètes tout ce dont tu as besoin.
Et hop, tu vas nourrir ta population.
Sauf que si tu n’entretiens pas bien tes puits de pétrole, et qu’en plus le prix du pétrole se casse la gueule.
Tu ne peux plus acheter tout ce dont ta population a besoin pour vivre.
Tous les gens qui sont employés dans des services, du jour au lendemain, leur argent ne sert plus à rien. Tu peux continuer de les payer, mais ils vont dans les magasins et il n’y a rien dans les magasins. Tu ne produis pas.
Et pour l’acheter, il te faut des dollars. Dollar que tu n’arrives pas à avoir. Tu produis moins de pétrole et le pétrole coûte moins cher.
Donc ton pays, il s’enfonce dans la crise.
Tu fais des bitcoins.
C’est pas ouf ça non plus.
Très bonne conclusion.